j'avais pas le coeur j'avais
besoin
je suis Gilou je suis ce Nicolas m'a
parlé de vous je suis ton barman
préférée
merci beaucoup
par la cuisine
comme ça je vais savoir ce qu'on mange
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut là celui-ci
il fait un documentaire sur toi tu
imagines ça va
tu es l'objet d'un tu es l'objet d'un
site web
[Musique]
dit que les conneries mais je lui ai dit
que notre brouille à l'époque était
quand même très médiatique et pas
vraiment fondamental
et puis en plus les choses bougent j'ai
besoin de me chamailler et et
en fait tu m'avais jamais rien fait à
moi simplement il y avait des trucs qui
m'avaient énervé et voilà et je dis les
choses c'est fini
bon alors au revoir merci beaucoup
monsieur Bedos c'est un peu de champagne
il te suit partout oui oui oui ça fait
plusieurs fois que qu'on me fait le nerf
de
chaque fois
j'avais envie de renouer avec le métier
d'acteur après avoir joué la pièce de
Nicolas et
j'en ai 200 des textes et j'ai fait moi
mon choix de mon point de vue à moi le
meilleur de moi-même et c'est des
personnages qui ne devraient pas se
rencontrer je l'ai composé ce spectacle
un peu musicalement tu vois avec des
voix différentes je fais un numéro
d'acteur et ça dure une heure et j'ai à
peu près 40 minutes de revue de presse
parce que si je l'avais pas la revue de
presse il y aura des plaintes
d'abord je m'amuse j'avais décidé de ne
pas justement faire un meeting ça c'est
fini le manichéisme des années 80 etc
quand
Giscard Mitterrand était rivaux j'avais
dit que
un bobineau et que je n'en sortirai que
le dîner j'avais fait ma dernière le 10
mai quand le diamantaire aura quitté
l'Élysée c'était donc ça mon projet et
il a dit d'ailleurs après ce qui était
plutôt flatteur pour moi pour Coluche
pour pour Charlie Hebdo qu'il avait été
battu par les forces de la dérision et
le fait que certaines des phrases que je
disais dans mon spectacle ont été
reprises à la Bastille le soir
et scander comme des slogans j'ai pas
demandé de droit d'auteur mais c'était
plutôt flatteur mais aujourd'hui c'est
plus dur je pense pas que maintenant on
vote plus pour votre compte selon ses
convictions
[Musique]
c'est chez toi que j'ai appelé à voter
cher on a tous voté Chirac
mais il s'en souvient pas tout le temps
ça va
[Musique]
il est à la fois mon producteur dans un
film que j'ai fait alors oui
je voulais te faire un cadeau parce que
c'est j'ai écrit un j'ai écrit des
textes pour un bouquin à success story
du Président c'est un recueil de dessin
des mecs de Charlie et je dis à
l'éditeur je vois Bedos ce soir il y en
a un bouquin il dit oui je t'en envoie
un il m'envoie le bouquin et voilà ce
qu'il y a dedans
il est vraiment collector parce que
c'est un bilan c'est le vrai bilan
alors vous faites un truc ensemble le
moyen-âge non c'est ça l'homme
un moyen âge non je lui ai proposé un
titre qui était des interminables mais
il pense que dans un terminal il y a
minable alors je t'explique en deux mots
au départ ça s'appelle les milieux c'est
de prendre
Dieu de milieu c'est nul mais tu sais
bien qu'on en fait pas désolé et donc
l'idée c'était de dire on est en 2050
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que nous on
devient qu'est-ce que notre génération
de 50 nerfs je parlais même pas de lui
qu'est-ce qu'on devient dans 50 ans on
imaginant que la science a fait
suffisamment de progrès pour qu'on
puisse vivre jusqu'à 1203
de la création oui parce que je crois
qu'on va crevé dans un mois dans une
vingtaine d'années je vais y passer
sur deux qui naît
en 2000 centenaire donc c'est un truc il
faut quand même un moment s'interroger
sur le problème donc tu imagines les
mecs dans 50 ans comment ils sont et
ils ont le droit de vivre tant qu'ils
veulent mais si dépendent de la société
euthanasie non pas le droit de dépendre
c'est un peu un monde libéral non mais
c'est un peu dur voilà c'est très très
bien c'est très bien parce qu'on dirait
pas un film français il y a des
personnages
virtuels
sur des écrans il s'est fait avoir
une sorte de bizutage
c'est très bon mais alors excuse-moi
qu'est-ce comment tu fais toujours pas
compris comment tu mets le programme
Jean-François Piège du crayon comment tu
mets le liquide dedans avec une seringue
non non on le fait refroidir et quand il
effront le panne et quand on le cuit la
panure devient croustillante et à chaud
le foie gras cliquez ici donc celui qui
croque dedans
super bon très bon c'est énorme mais
alors il faut le mettre tout de suite
dans l'arrière bouche
c'est ça qu'il faut manger tous les
jours mais attends moi je suis de la
gauche couscous je ne suis pas de la
gauche caviar
et les mecs ils ont trouvé un truc
c'est un produit
qui leur les capteurs du cerveau c'est
quand tu fumes les capteurs ils sont
contents parce qu'ils ont de la nicotine
ouais
tu prends ça tu as plus envie de fumer
parce que c'est comme si tu faisais
d'écraser la dernière c'est génial ça
moi je le veux ça
c'est pas possible je sais que je note
un peu mon son que vous êtes réconcilié
tous les deux parce que vous commencez
vous échanger des maladies des
médicaments tout ça vous appelle ça à
Paris c'est Drucker à un moment m'a fait
peur avec un truc bon bref il met à tous
les portables de tout ce qui compte dans
la médecine
je te jure et là il m'a dit je suis non
seulement hypocondriaque mais je suis
hypocroyal pour mes amis donc parce que
à un moment je jouais la piste vu que là
et je joue un poitriner à l'époque et je
touchais beaucoup et je vais voir on me
dit le type me dit qui est un jeune
pneumologue je lui dis ça peut aller de
la simple inflammation à la tumeur comme
dirait des proches à tumeur je meurs
alors moi comme je suis un peu
joueur même dans le hard je lui demande
si j'ai une tumeur qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire il décrit tout ce qu'on va faire
évidemment je téléphone à un médecin ami
pour qu'il prépare une fiole pour en
finir c'est tellement dur c'est
tellement bouleversant il y a tellement
humiliant que je n'irai pas jusque là si
je peux si je peux si je peux c'est moi
qui déciderai je suis très proche d'une
association j'ai jamais de carte de rien
mais je suis très proche de cette
question qui s'appelle le droit de
mourir dans la dignité je mon chien est
mort de la dignité je veux mourir comme
mon chien
mais je peux finir sur le sur ta fiole
normalement c'est quand la déchéance
arrive mais quand la déchéance arrive tu
es tu y es plus ta tête elle est plus là
à quel moment c'est toi qui décide
si on me dit que je vais
mais
j'ai participé à des États-Unis
tranquillement moi je n'ai pas peur de
la mort j'ai peur de la peur de la mort
c'est rien à mort quand on a été
quand on était anesthésié une fois dans
sa vie c'est une sorte de bande-annonce
tu demandes-annonce de la mort quand tu
te réveilles tu es tout étonné d'être là
encore c'est le moment le plus pénible
très agréable
c'est la péridurale moi je me suis fait
enlever on va parler maladie mais on est
vraiment plus à ce point-là
moi j'ai demandé une péridurale pour un
ménisque ce que je voulais absolument
voir l'opération donc ils amènent un psy
en disant que vous êtes capable de
supporter
il y a un champ opératoire tu vois pas
directement mais tu vois sur un écran
oui je regarde sur l'écran le mec qui
enlève le ménis qui est tout ça deux
heures après il y a un type baraque qui
se pointe qui est kiné qui dit debout et
que commence à deux bouts qui te fait
marcher comment cette plier la guibole
et tout donc ça va super vite je me
retrouve donc allongée mais bon
maintenant ça va vous avez marché tout
ça reposez-vous et je commence à vouloir
bouger les orteils et je peux pas et tu
es complètement lucide et les orteils tu
donnes l'ordre de bougie il bouge pas
bon alors tu attends une heure et demie
après les orteils commencent à bouger tu
dis ça y est c'est revenu et tout
revient sauf la je mets la main sur
ma et je la sens plus c'est pas
possible le seul truc qui revient pas
c'est l'habitude
qui fait du sport et moi aussi mon
endroit
de gymnastique par semaine moi aussi
faites moi aussi moi je fais au moins
trois fois par semaine une heure de
cardio et
un peu de muscu
il est très très il est bon je peux en
hétéro si tu es militant il est très
bizarre mais c'est où vous faites du
sport les filles
vous faites du sport
[Musique]
si on a tout on a tout essayé ça se
passe bien
qui a la blague un peu coquine facile
quand moi je m'attendais à faire
attention à tout ce que je dis et tout
non non
qu'est-ce qu'il dit alors moi Patrick
Sébastien
dans les loges
mais sur le plateau je vous ai trouvé
super beau et la première chose que j'ai
demandé mais j'étais persuadée que
Charles Berling était homosexuel j'étais
persuadée que vous étiez en fait
rétablissement
mais t'imagines le désastre quand elle
me dit ça ça fait bon donc
il y en a beaucoup qui savent que je me
suis
il y a un chiffre de 1 à 6 Virginie 6
attention
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne d'abord
tu es donc la reine de la soirée encore
ici mon mari est très jeune
donc maintenant tu peux tromper ton mari
plus mon éducation catholique bourgeoise
ça n'existe pas moi je suis persuadé que
ça n'existe
si même suffisamment pour faire semblant
qu'elle sort un album l'emmener en
studio lui fera enregistre un disque il
a le droit de tirer son coup j'ai en
voudrait pas
et dis-moi tu l'as rencontré où Virginie
que le mec avec qui j'étais organisé
ensemble
je l'ai vu et puis il m'a donné clé de
chez lui j'ai emménagé chez lui et voilà
je prends mes affaires je suis parti
cette soirée à 24 heures
Bruno et moi et que Charles
donc qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus que Guy
Bedos
cuisine direct
et il publie un livre que si si c'est
très intéressant il publie un livre où
il raconte son grand-père donc Jean
Bedel les diamants de Giscard ce qui ne
manquera pas de t'intéresser évidemment
quand j'ai vu Bokassa le sacre de
Bokassa dans match
j'ai eu le même sentiment imagine à
l'époque des royalistes quoi à l'époque
de Napoléon qui voyait Napoléon se faire
sacrer empereur c'est-à-dire que pour
eux c'était terrible parce que les mecs
étaient royalistes il y avait des
Bourbons qui étaient sur le trône depuis
des siècles et d'un seul coup vous
arrivez ce mec à mettre 12 qui arrive de
Corse et qui commence à se faire sacré
par le pape avec un appareil
extraordinaire et en fait on peut
comprendre ce que ça a été en regardant
le sacre de Bokassa cirque il s'est fait
sacré dans une espèce de décorum
absolument
déjà mais en fait je voulais aussi
raconter les gens ce que les gens ne
savent pas c'est que dans ma famille on
a une famille de notable depuis des
générations son propre père était
gouverneur de la Centrafrique
oui tout à fait il est mort
donc après il a dû se construire tout
seul mais son arrière grand oncle était
le premier président de la Centrafrique
et alors c'était quoi ces diamants
sérieusement vous qui êtes
l'histoire des diamants c'est pas grand
chose en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que vous savez le chef d'État quand ils
sont en voyage diplomatique qui se font
des cadeaux d'État et mon grand-père
considérait en Afrique en fait on va
vous offrir ce qu'on considère le plus
beau dans le pays donc pour mon
grand-père ce qui représentait de plus
beau pour son pays c'était les diamants
donc il a offert ça
comme cadeau d'État et normalement un
cadeau d'État on le met à l'Élysée quand
on le ressent le paille le plus beau
gosse c'est d'abord menti c'est le
mensonge qui tue tu peux pas dire c'est
que une histoire de diamant machin et
puis il sait pas ce qu'il a menti quand
un président d'une République est copain
avec un dictateur
maladie mental complètement débile c'est
le
fonds
Centrafrique c'était quand même la
pauvreté du peuple ils avaient une
pauvreté extraordinaire
en France non non faut pas exagérer il
faut pas exagérer c'était un empereur
d'opérette complet et l'autre était
copains avec juste parce qu'il a les
chasser là-bas à la chasser avec nous
avec ses grands machins arrête c'est
dégoûtant c'est absolument dégoûtant et
innommable
mais ça doit pas être simple de
s'appeler bokasse
je réalise en grandissant que c'est
beaucoup plus simple pour moi de
m'appeler Bokassa dans le monde dans
lequel on vit que Mamadou
c'est vrai que à un moment on meurt et
moi je ne crois pas la vie éternelle je
pense pas que je peux baiser des vierges
ou pas
du tout donc tu le fais maintenant voilà
tu me connais bien toi
je vais pas vous raconter ma vie mais
je suis séparé
je me suis beaucoup dissipé et vraiment
ça allait très fort pour moi ça allait
bon mais
j'en ai eu assez
il m'est arrivé de de demander un taxi à
des femmes
ravissante mais
j'avais pas le cœur j'avais vu
je suis sûr que tu visais pas si haut
que le cœur
Bref et elles m'ont pris à la fois pour
un homo et ou pour un impuissant non
j'avais plus envie parce que j'avais
plus avec qui j'étais je pleure prénom
je prenais le petit déjeuner avec des
filles
beaucoup oui
il y a longtemps de la même femme qui
est la mère de Nicolas et Victoria c'est
28 ans qu'on est marié et c'est pas
seulement pour plaire à ma femme que je
dis ça
l'amour avec le temps l'amour coeur en
tout cas ce fortifie
et ça devient parce qu'on a construit
quelque chose parce que pardon là c'est
très très bourgeois ce que je vais dire
mais on a des enfants qu'on aime
ensemble et ça donne ensemble etc et on
a construit et c'est une histoire tu as
raison c'est une belle histoire et et
donc
peut-être que ça vaut la peine de
renoncer à certaines aventures
un peu facultative
qui ne débouchent sur pas grand chose
voilà ce que tu dis cette longévité par
le cœur je le comprends très bien mais
en prenant aussi du plaisir par le cul
par ailleurs pourquoi est-ce que tu
pourrais pas le faire
ouvertement tromper c'est ça veut dire
quoi tromper ça veut dire que tu trompes
si tu mens l'amour
est-ce que je ne supporterai pas de ma
femme je veux pas le lui imposer mais ça
c'est parce que tes pieds-noirs c'est
parce que tu as aussi
parce que c'est une culture aussi ça et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu